another day another protest in panama
thousands of people marched once again
to demand measures to curb inflation and
corruption in the central american
country they've been out on the streets
almost daily for the past two
the weeks situation in panama is
unlivable there are no medical supplies
there are salary cuts and there's no
work there's no money to pay doctors as
a student the future worries me a lot
on wednesday indigenous groups joined
teachers students and other unions in
the demonstrations promising to further
deepen the crisis
we call on the president of the republic
to heed our request if he does not
respond to our petition we will mobilize
the indigenous territories of panama
on monday president laurentino cortiso
announced a reduction in the price of
fuel now the government has presented a
decree controlling the price of 10 basic
food items among them lentils and
vegetable oil
it also promised to slash government
public spending by 10 percent
but for protesters these measures don't
go far enough
hotdog vendor jose gonzalez says the
situation is the worst he's seen in
decades
with the rise in fuel costs everything
became more expensive the bread the hot
dogs and not sensemore it has doubled in
23 years doing this job i'd never seen
so many people working informally on the
streets i don't think the government is
offering real solutions
solutions that panamanians are becoming
increasingly impatient for alessandra
ampietti al jazeera